October 1996 Rancho Santa Fe California
Marshall Applewhite and his followers
have created a website which outlines
their beliefs and explains how one may
enter Heaven's Gate it is the name with
which the group will be permanently
associated what is the meaning of
Heaven's Gate according to the website
it means that Applewhite and nettles are
the keys to the kingdom of heaven income
from the group's new computer consulting
business called higher source enables
them to rent this nine thousand square
foot residence in an affluent
neighborhood near San Diego but former
member Rio de Angelo says the group's
main focus was their impending suicide
we felt really good and how we had to
prepare so we knew that the exit was at
that time in a minute
Applewhite says he is waiting for a sign
from the next level which will tell him
when it is time for the group to leave
the planet until then his followers make
preparations they check their supply of
phenobarbital a powerful barbiturate
which can cause death when combined with
alcohol they purchased it in Mexico
months earlier they work out a suicide
schedule and they create uniforms we all
had uniforms made for us and we went out
and got Nike sneakers on sale for ten
bucks
DeAngelo designs the Heaven's Gate away
team arm patches we were considered an
away team like from a spacecraft like in
Star Trek the away team goes down to the
planet does what they have to do and
then they come back up
December 1996 the newly discovered
hale-bopp comet moves closer to the
earth
Applewhite announces to his followers
that this is the sign he has been
waiting for
he says the spaceships will soon be
arriving to take them home to the level
above human the reason that the comet
was the indicator was that it was
something that you could see anywhere in
the world and he felt that the next
level would give him a sign in that way
but shortly after Applewhite's
declaration diangelo starts having
doubts I felt like there was something
more that I needed to do and I it was a
confusing to me because I I loved oh and
I loved the group
with Applewhite's blessing D'Angelo
decides to leave
March 19th 1997 in the backyard of their
home Heaven's Gate members videotape one
another issuing farewell messages to the
world step have to save my life I mean
I'm not looking for this for so long